un parcours de 5 km le long des rives de
l'indre en plein coeur de satoru 43
concurrents reconnaissables à leur tee
shirt jaune et malgré leur décontraction
apparente une âme de compétiteur car la
discipline implique une vigilance de
tous les instants
on change les couleurs la taille du
leurre l'animation parce que ça reste
qu'un bout de plastique un bout de métal
donc du coup il faut vraiment être au
top et les jeunes adorent ça la
compétition consiste à attraper le plus
de poissons possible qu'il faut mesurer
photographier et inscrire sur la feuille
officielle avant bien sûr de rejeter à
l'eau laprise supplément ce que c'est
d'abord parce que c'est une pépite in
itinérante on est tout le temps en
mouvement et c'est un peu une sorte de
traque du poisson et on est à la
recherche du poisson on lance pas notre
ligne on n'attend pas les street fisher
autrement dit p soeur de rue ont des
lancers très léger et surtout tout un
attirail qu'il transporte sur leur
parcours
car un spot trouver un poisson repéré il
faut encore avoir la ligne qui convient
on change en fonction du la rivière s'il
ya des nénuphars silos et profonde si un
peu de haut tout dépend de
l'environnement
vous avez combien d'heures là avec vous
environ je dirais peut-être une
cinquantaine c'est beaucoup on se serait
ce plus encore car en plus des leurres
souples
ils y allaient rigide mais avec un
équipement de base de 50 euros on peut
s'adonner aux joies de cette pêche
urbaine et celui qui aura gagné la
compétition repartira avec un lancer
cinq fois plus cher
de quoi motiver nos jeunes pêcheurs